The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today we begin our final block
of material in this particular
course, and it's the segment
entitled Infinite Series.
And perhaps the best way to
motivate this rather difficult
block of material is in
terms of the concept
of many versus infinite.
In many respects, this
particular block could've been
given much earlier
in the course.
But somehow or other, until we
have some sort of a feeling as
to what infinity really means,
we have a maturity problem in
trying to really grasp
the significance of
what's going on.
In fact, in a manner of
speaking, with all of this
experience, there may be a
maturity problem in trying to
grasp the fundamental ideas.
What I shall do throughout the
material on this block is to
utilize the lectures again to
make sure that the concepts
become crystallized and use the
learning exercises plus
the text plus supplements notes
to make sure that the
details are taken care of
in adequate fashion.
At any rate, I've entitle
today's lecture
'Many Versus Infinite'.
And I thought the best way to
get started on this was to
think of a number that's very
easy to write in terms of
exponential notation.
Let capital 'N' be 10 to the
10 to the 10th power.
10 to the 10, by the way,
is 10 billion, a 1
followed by 10 zeroes.
That's 10 to the 10-billionth
power.
That, of course, means, if
written in place value, that
would be a 1 followed by
10 billion zeroes.
And for those of you who would
like an exercise in
multiplication and long division
and you want to
compute the number of seconds
in a year and what have you,
it turns out without
too much difficulty
that it can be shown.
That to write 1 billion zeroes
at the rate of one per second
would take in the order of
magnitude of some 32 years.
In other words, this number
capital 'N', roughly speaking,
writing it in place value
notation at the rate of one
digit per second would take
320 years to write.
And you say so what?
And the answer is, well, after
you've got out that far-- and
by the way, this is crucial.
320 years is a long time.
I was going to say
it's a lifetime.
It's more than the lifetime.
It's a long time,
but it's finite.
Eventually, the job could
be completed.
But the interesting point is
that once it's completed, the
next number in our system is
capital 'N plus 1', capital 'N
plus 2', capital 'N plus 3',
where in a sense then, with
'N' as a new reference point,
we're back to the beginning of
our number system.
In other words, granted that 'N'
is a fantastically large
number, if you wanted to become
wealthy, to own 'N'
dollars would more than
realize your dream.
But if your aim was to own
infinitely much money, 'N'
would be no closer than having
no money at all. 'N' is no
nearer the end of a number
system than is
the number 1 itself.
There is the story that
signifies the difference
between many and infinite.
And to hammer this point
home, let me give
you a few more examples.
I cleverly call this additional
examples.
We all know that there are just
as many odd numbers and
even numbers, right?
The odds and the
evens match up.
Now, watch the following
little gimmick.
Write the first two odd numbers,
then the first even
number, the next two odd
numbers, then the next even
number, the next two
odd numbers, than
the next even number.
And go on like this as
long as you want.
And no matter where we stop,
even if we go to the 10 to the
10 to the 10th term, no matter
what even number we stop at,
there will always be twice as
many odd numbers written on
the board as there would
be even numbers.
In other words, even though in
the long run in terms of the
infinity of each there are as
many odds and evens, if we
stop this process at any finite
time no matter how far
out, there will always
be twice as many odds
as there are evens.
In fact, if you want to compound
this little dilemma,
write the first two evens, then
an odd, in other words,
2, 4, 1, 6, 8, 3, 10, 12, 5, and
you can get twice as many
evens as there are
odds, et cetera.
And the whole argument
again hinges on what?
Confusing the concept of
going out very far
with going out endlessly.
Oh, let me give you another
example or two.
I just want to throw these
around so you at least get the
mood created as to what we're
really dealing with right now.
Let's take the endless sequence
of numbers, the sum,
1 plus 'minus 1' plus 1
plus 'minus 1', and
say let's go on forever.
What will this sum be?
Now, lookit, one
way of grouping
these terms is in twos.
In other words, we'll start with
the first two terms, the
next two terms.
In other words, we can write
this as 1 plus minus 1 plus 1
plus minus 1.
And writing it this way, we can
see that each term adds up
to 0, and the infinite
sum would be 0.
On the other hand, if we now
leave the first term alone and
now start grouping the remaining
terms in twos, we
find that the infinite
sum is 1.
Now, we're not going to argue
that something is fishy here.
We're not going to say
I wonder which
is the right answer.
What we have shown without fear
of contradiction is that
the answer that you get when you
add infinitely many terms
does depend on how you group
them, unlike the situation of
what happens when you add
finitely many terms.
In other words, notice the need
for order as well as the
terms themselves when
you have a sum of
infinitely many terms.
And the key point is don't be
upset when you find out that
your intuition is defied here.
You say this doesn't
seem real to me.
It seems intuitively false.
The point is our intuition
is defied.
Why?
Because it doesn't apply.
And why doesn't it apply?
It doesn't apply because our
intuition is based on
visualizing large but finite
amounts, not based on
visualizing infinity.
You see, all of these paradoxes
stem, because in our
mind, we're trying to visualize
infinity as meaning
the same as very large.
Well, you know, now we come to
a very important crossroad.
After all, if infinity is going
to be this difficult a
concept to handle, let's get
rid of it the easy way.
Let's refuse to study it.
That's one way of solving
problems.
It's what I call the right wing
conservative educational
philosophy.
If you don't like something,
throw it out.
The only trouble
is we need it.
For example, why
do we need it?
See, why deal with
infinite sums?
Well, because we need them.
Among other places, we've
already used them.
For example, in computing
areas.
We've taken a limit as
'N' goes to infinity.
Summation, 'k' goes from 1 to
'n', 'f of 'c sub k'' 'delta
x', you see.
And we need this limit.
And so the question comes up,
how shall we add infinitely
many terms?
We have a choice now.
We can throw the thing
out, but we don't
want to throw it out.
We need it.
So the question is how shall we
add infinitely many terms?
And even though we know that
our intuition can get us in
trouble, we do have nothing
else to begin with.
So we say OK, let's mimic what
happened in the finite case
and see if we can't extend that
in a plausible way to
cover the infinite case.
Let me pick a particularly
straightforward example.
Let's suppose I have the three
numbers which I'll call 'a sub
1', 'a sub 2', and 'a sub 3',
where 'a sub 1' will be 1/2,
'a sub 2' will be 1/4, and
'a sub 3' will be 1/8.
In other words, just for reasons
of identification
later on in what I'm going to be
doing, each term is half of
the previous one.
Now, I want to find the sum
of these three terms.
I want to find 'a1' plus
'a2' plus 'a3'.
Now, colloquially, we just say,
oh, that's 1/2 plus 1/4
plus 1/8, and I'll
just add them up.
But do you remember how
you learned to add?
You may not have paid attention
to it, but you
learned to add as a sequence.
You said I'll add
the first one.
Then the first plus the second
gives me a number.
That's my second partial sum.
Then I'll add on the
third number.
That will give me my
third partial sum.
Then I have no more
numbers to add.
Consequently, my third partial
sum is by definition the sum
of these three numbers.
Writing it more symbolically,
we say lookit, the first
partial sum, 's sub
1', is 1/2.
The second partial sum
as 1/2 plus 1/4.
Another way of saying
that is what?
It's the first partial
sums plus the next
term, which is 1/4.
1/2 plus 1/4 is 3/4.
Then we said OK, the third
partial sum is what we had
before, namely, 3/4, plus the
next term, which was 1/8, and
that gives rise to 7/8.
In other words, we said let's
form 'a1', then 'a1 plus a2',
'a1 plus a2 plus a3'.
And when we finally finished
with our sequence of partial
sums, the last partial
sum was the answer.
And by the way, let me take time
out here to hit home at
the most important point, the
point that I think is
extremely crucial as a starting
point if we're going
to understand what this whole
block is all about.
It's to distinguish between
a series and a sequence.
And I'll have much more to
say about this in the
supplementary notes.
But for now, think
of it this way.
A series is a sum of terms.
A sequence is just a
listing of terms.
In other words, in this
particular problem, do not
confuse the role of the 'a's
with the role of the 's's.
Notice that the a's refer
to the sequence of
numbers being added.
In other words, the
'a's were what?
They were 1/2, 1/4 and 1/8.
These were the three numbers
being added.
Notice that the 's's were
the partial sums.
In other words, the partial sums
form the sequence 's1',
's2', 's3'.
And to refresh your memories
on this, that would be the
sequence what?
1/2, 3/4, 7/8.
In other words, this was the sum
of the first number that
you were adding.
3/4 was the sum of first two,
and 7/8 was the sum of all
three of them.
And notice, by the way, the last
partial sum, 's sub 3',
the sum was defined to
be the last partial
sum, and that is what?
The number--
this is very, very crucial.
1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 is the sum
of three numbers, but it's
one number, and that number
is called 7/8.
OK, you see what we're
talking about now?
We're looking at a
bunch of terms.
We're adding them up, and
we see how the sum
changes with each term.
In fact, in terms of a very
trivial analogy, think of an
adding machine.
As you punch numbers in, the
's's are the sums that you see
being read as your total sum,
whereas the a's are the
individual numbers being punched
in to add up, OK?
I hope that's a trivial
example.
As I listen to myself saying it,
it sounds like I made it
harder than it really is.
At any rate, let's generalize
this particular problem.
Let's suppose now instead of
wanting to add 1/2 plus 1/4
plus 1/8, we want to add up
the first 'n' terms of the
form 1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8.
In other words, let the n-th
term that we're going to add,
'a sub n', be '1 over
'2 to the n''.
Then the sum, the n-th partial
sum here, the sum of these 'n'
terms is, of course,
what? 'a1' plus, et
cetera, 'a sub n'.
That turns out to be 1/2 plus
1/4 plus, et cetera, '1 over
'2 to the n''.
And by the way, rather than
take time to develop this
recipe over here, I thought you
might like to see another
place that might be interesting
to review
mathematical induction.
If you'll bear with me and just
come back over here where
we were computing these partial
sums, notice that in
each of these partial sums,
notice that your denominator
is always 2 raised to the same
power as this subscript.
See, 2 the first power is 2.
2 to the second power is 4.
2 to the third power is 8.
In other words, if your
subscript is n, your
denominator is '2 to the n'.
Notice that your numerator is
always one less than your
denominator.
In other words, if your
denominator is '2 to the n',
the numerator is '2 to
the 'n minus 1''.
And once we suspect this, this
particular result can be
proven by induction.
I won't take the time
to do this here.
What I will take the time to
do is to observe that this
particular sum can be written
more conveniently if we divide
through by '2 to the n-th'
to get 1 minus
'1 over '2 the n''.
For example, suppose we wanted
to add up the 10 numbers.
I say 10 numbers here.
2 to the 10th is 1.024.
But according to this recipe,
1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 plus
1/16 plus, et cetera, et cetera,
plus 1/1,024 would add
up to be what?
1 minus 1/1,024.
In other words, this would be
1,023/1,024, which seems to be
pretty close to 1.
In fact, you can begin to
suspect that as 'n' gets
arbitrarily large, 's sub
n' gets arbitrarily
close to 1 in value.
I'm just talking fairly
intuitively
for the time being.
But, you see, the major question
now is suppose you
elect not to stop at that.
And you see, this is
a very key point.
We've already seen how the whole
world seems to change as
soon as you say let's never
stop as opposed to saying
let's go out as far
as you want.
See, if we now say what
happens if you go on
endlessly over here?
Well, it becomes very natural
to say lookit, the n-th
partial sum was 1 minus '1
over '2 to the n-th'.
In the case where you were
adding up a finite number of
terms, when you came to the last
partial sum, that was by
definition your answer.
Now, what we're saying is
lookit, because we have
infinitely many terms to add,
there is no last partial sum.
And so what we say is lookit,
instead of the last term,
since there is no last term,
why don't we just take the
limit of the n-th partial sum
as 'n' goes to infinity.
In other words, in this
particular case, notice that
as 'n' approaches infinity, 1
minus '1 over '2 to the n''
approaches 1, and we then
define the infinite sum,
meaning what?
I write it this way: as sigma
'n' goes from 1 to infinity,
'1 over '2 to the n''.
It really means what?
The limit as 'n' goes to
infinity: 1/2 plus 1/4 plus
1/8 plus 1/16--
endlessly--
that that limit is 1, and we
define that to be the sum.
And again, as I say, I'm going
to write that in greatly more
detail in the notes, and
also we'll have many
exercises on this.
I just wanted you to see how we
get to infinite sums, which
are called series by
generalizing what happens in
the finite case.
And because this may seem a
little vague to you, let me
give you a pictorial
representation
of this same thing.
You see, what's happening
here is this.
Draw a little circle around
1 of bandwidth epsilon.
In other words, let's mark off
an interval epsilon on
either side of 1.
And let's call this point
here 1 minus epsilon.
Let's call this point
here 1 plus epsilon.
And what we're saying about
our partial sums is this.
That when you start off and
you're adding up terms here,
you have 1/2.
1/2 plus 1/4 brings
you over to 3/4.
The next possible sum
is 7/8, et cetera.
And all we're saying is that
these terms get arbitrarily
close to 1 in value, meaning
that after a while--
and I'll define more rigorously
what after a while
means in a moment--
all of the 's sub n's are
within epsilon of 1.
After a while, all of your
partial sums are in here.
And what you mean by after a
while certainly depends on how
big epsilon is.
In other words, the smaller
the bandwidth you allow
yourself, the more terms you
may have to take before you
get within the tolerance limits
that you allow yourself.
In any event, going back to
something that we've been
using for a long
time, our basic
definition is the following.
If you have an infinite
sequence, say, a collection of
terms 'b sub n', in other words,
'b1', 'b2', 'b3', et
cetera, without end, we say that
that sequence converges
to the limit 'L' written the
limit of 'b sub n' as 'n'
approaches infinity equals 'L',
if and only if for every
epsilon greater than 0 we can
find a number 'N' which
depends on epsilon--
notice the notation here: 'N'
as a function of epsilon--
such that whenever little 'n'
is greater than capital 'N',
the absolute value of
'a sub n' minus 'L'
is less than epsilon.
And, you see, again, you may
wonder how in the world that
you're going to remember this.
If you memorize this, I
guarantee you, in two day's
time, you'll have to
memorize it again.
I also hope you have enough
faith in me to recognize I
didn't memorize this.
There is a feeling that
one gets for this.
And let me give you what
that feeling is.
Again, in terms of a picture,
what it means-- well, I'll
change these to 'a's now because
that's the symbols
that we've been using
before in terms of
the sequence of terms.
What we really mean-- and I
don't care what symbol you
really use here--
is if you want to talk about the
limit of 'a sub n' as 'n'
approaches infinity, if that
limit equals 'L', what the
rigorous definition
says is this.
Draw yourself an interval
around 'L' of bandwidth
epsilon, in other words,
from 'L minus
epsilon' to 'L plus epsilon'.
And what this thing says is that
beyond a certain term,
say, the capital N-th term,
every term beyond this certain
one is in here.
Well, all 'a n's are in here if
'n' is sufficiently large.
I don't know if you can read
that very well, but just
listen to what I'm saying.
All of the terms are in here if
'n' is sufficiently large.
What this means again is that
to all intents and purposes,
if you think of this bandwidth
as giving you a dot, see, a
thick dot here where the
endpoints are 'L minus
epsilon' and 'L plus epsilon',
what we're saying is lookit,
after a certain term, the way
I've drawn here, after the
fifth term, all the remaining
terms of my
sequence are in here.
By the way, notice the role
of the subscripts here.
All the subscript tells
you is where the term
appears in your sequence.
For example, the third term in
your sequence could be a
smaller number than the second
term of your sequence.
Do not confuse the size of the
terms with the subscripts.
The subscripts order the terms,
but the third term in
the sequence can be less than
in size than the second term
in the sequence.
But again, I'll talk
about that in more
detail in the notes.
The point that I want you to
see is that in concept what
limit does is the following.
Limit is to an infinite sequence
as last term is to a
finite sequence.
In other words, a limit replaces
infinitely many
points by a finite number
of points plus a dot.
You see, going back to this
example here, how many 'a sub
n's were there?
Well, there were infinitely
many.
Well, to keep track of these
infinitely many, what do I
have to keep track of now?
Well, in this diagram, the first
five 'a's plus this dot,
because you see, every one of
my infinitely many 'a's past
the fifth one is inside
this dot, you see?
So in other words then,
what's happened?
The thing that had to happen.
We had to deal with infinite
sequences.
We saw the big philosophic
difference between infinitely
many and just large.
And so our definition of limit
had to be such that we could
reduce in a way that was
compatible with our intuition
the concept of infinitely many
points to a finite number.
Because, you see, as I'll show
you in the notes also, all of
our arithmetic is geared for
just a finite number of
operations.
See, this is why
this definition
of limit is so crucial.
Again, you may notice, and I'll
remind you of this also
in the exercises, that
structurally this definition
of limit is the same as the
limit that we use when we
talked about the limit of 'f of
x', as 'x' approaches 'a',
equals 'L'.
The absolute value signs have
the same properties as before.
And by the way, before I go
on, let me just remind you
again of one more thing while
I'm talking that way.
Instead of memorizing this,
remember how you read this.
The absolute value of 'a sub
n' minus 'L' is less than
epsilon means what?
That 'a sub n' is within
epsilon of 'L'.
That's what we use
in our diagram.
But it seems to me I forgot
to mention this.
And I want you to
see that what?
The key building block
analytically is the absolute
value, and the meaning of
absolute value is the same
here as it was in blocks one
and two of our course.
So what I'm driving at is that
the same limit theorems that
we've been able to use up
until now still apply.
Oh, by means of an example.
Suppose I have the limit as 'n'
approaches infinity, '2n
plus 3' over '5n plus 7'.
Notice that I can divide
numerator and denominator
through by 'n'.
If I do that, I have the limit
as 'n' approaches infinity.
'2 plus '3/n'' over
'5 plus '7/n''.
Now using the fact that the
limit of a sum is the sum of
the limits, the limit of a
quotient is the quotient of
the limits, the limit of '1/n'
as 'n' goes to infinity is 0.
Notice that I can use the limit
theorems to conclude
that the limit of this
particular sequence is 2/5.
If I wanted to, the same ways
we did in block one, block
two, where we're talking about
limits, given an epsilon, I
can actually exhibit how far out
I have to go before each
of the terms in this sequence
is within that
given epsilon of 2/5.
By the way, again to emphasize
once more, because this is so
important, the difference
between an infinite sum and an
infinite sequence, observe that
whereas the limit of the
sequence of terms '2n plus 3'
over '5n plus 7' is 2/5, the
infinite sum composed of the
terms of the form '2n plus 3'
over '5n plus 7' is infinity
since after a while each term
that you're adding here
behaves like 2/5.
In other words, if you write
this thing out to see what
this means, pick 'n' to be 1.
When 'n' is 1, this
term is 5/12.
When 'n' is 2, this is what?
7 plus 17, 7/17.
When 'n' is 3, this is 9/22.
When 'n' is 4, this is 8
plus 3 is 11, over 27.
In other words, what you're
saying is the infinite sum
means to add up all
of these terms.
The thing whose limit was 2/5
was the sequence of terms
themselves.
In other words, what we're
saying is that after a certain
point, every one of these
terms behaves like 2/5.
And what you're saying is
lookit, after a point, what
you're really doing is
essentially adding on 2/5
every time you add
on another term.
And therefore, this sum can get
as large as you want, just
by adding on enough terms.
Again, observe the difference
between the partial sums and
the terms themselves.
The terms that you're
adding are
approaching 2/5 as a limit.
The thing that's becoming
infinite is the sequence of
partial sums.
Because what you're saying is to
get from one partial sum to
the next, you're, roughly
speaking,
adding on 2/5 each time.
To generalize this, what we're
saying is if the sequence of
partial sums converges, the
individual terms that you're
adding must approach
0 in the limit.
For if the limit of the 'a sub
n's as 'n' approaches infinity
is 'L', where 'L' is not 0, then
beyond a certain term,
the sum of the 'a sub
n's behaves like
the sum of the 'L's.
And what you're saying is if 'L'
is non zero, by adding on
enough of these fixed 'L's, you
can make the sum as large
as you wish.
In other words, then, a sort
of negative test is that if
you know that the series
converges, then the terms that
you're adding on must approach
0 in the limit.
Unfortunately, by the way,
the converse is not true.
Namely, if you know that the
terms that you're adding on go
to 0, you cannot conclude that
their sum is finite.
Again, it's our old friend
of infinity times 0.
You see, as these terms approach
0, when you start to
add them up, it may be
that they're not
going to 0 fast enough.
In other words, notice that the
terms are getting small,
but you're also adding more
and more of them.
You see, what I wrote
here is what?
On the other hand, the limit of
'a sub n' as 'n' approaches
infinity equals 0 is not
enough to guarantee the
convergence of this
particular sum.
In fact, a trivial example to
show this is look at the
following contrived example.
Start out with the first
number being 1.
Then take 1/2 twice, 1/3 three
times, 1/4 four times, 1/5
five times, 1/6 six times.
Form the n-th partial sum.
Lookit, is it clear that the
terms that are going into your
sum are approaching
0 in the limit?
You see, you have a one, then
there are halves, then thirds,
then fourths, then fifths,
then sixths,
sevenths, et cetera.
The terms themselves
are getting
arbitrarily close to 0.
On the other hand, what
is the sum becoming?
Well, this adds up to 1.
This adds up to 1.
This adds up to 1, and
this that up to 1.
And in other words, by taking
enough terms, I can tack on as
many ones is I want, and
ultimately, even though the
terms become small, the
sum becomes large.
In fact, it's precisely because
of this unpleasantness
that we have to go into a rather
difficult lecture next
time, talking about OK, how
then can you tell when an
infinite sum converges
to a finite limit and
when doesn't it?
At any rate, that's what
I said we're going to
talk about next time.
As far as today's lesson is
concerned, I hope that we've
straightened out the difference
between a sequence
and the series, partial sums
and the terms being added.
And in the hopes that we've done
that, let me say, until
next time, goodbye.
Funding for the publication of
this video was provided by the
Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.